-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
Well, guys, earlier tonight,
President Biden delivered
the State of the Union address.
Yep. Of course, Democrats
spent most of the night
clapping for Biden.
It wasn't for anything he said.
They were just trying to
keep him awake.
They were like, "Alright, hey...
Hey! Come on."
It was a tough night
for all of Biden's staffers
watching from The White House,
'cause every time
people clapped,
the lights went on and off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's the same thing every year.
One side stands and claps.
The other side sits still,
not having any fun.
It reminds me
of my cousin's wedding.
Yeah. "I give it six months!"
Now, Biden also talked about
his achievements.
He said, "We passed an
infrastructure bill,
we reduced inflation,
and we finally convinced
Tom Brady to retire."
So I think it's a great year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In his speech, Biden called
for bipartisanship and unity.
He was like,
"As Democrats and Republicans,
we have one common goal -- to
mishandle classified documents."
There was wall-to-wall coverage
of the State of the Union
on all the major networks,
like NBC, ABC, and CBS.
Meanwhile,
Netflix is like, "Ka-ching."
I read that Biden's approval
rating currently stands at 42%,
just above the 41% he had at
last year's State of the Union.
That's tough.
It's like eating kale
for an entire year,
then realizing you only lost
1 pound, and you go,
"I did this for a whole year."
At the State of the Union,
Biden was excited to talk about
all of his accomplishments.
I think he even wanted to mess
with China a little bit.
Take a look at
his entrance tonight.
-Mr. Speaker, the
President of the United States!
-♪ All I do is
win, win, win no matter what ♪
♪ Got money on my mind,
I can never get enough ♪
-That's how he entered.
That's how he entered.
-Just rubbing it in their face.
My goodness.
-That's an entrance right there.
-That is an entrance.
-Yeah. Well,
speaking of the balloon,
the U.S. Navy has
started to recover parts of
the Chinese balloon
that was shot down over
the Atlantic Ocean.
Not only did we find
the balloon,
all the Navy divers
came back speaking
in that funny helium voice.
[ High-pitched ]
"Mission accomplished!"
[ Normal voice ]
Listen to this, guys.
Today, Speaker Kevin McCarthy
suggested that
Congressman George Santos
will face a House investigation.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
The specific charges
are "everything."
Some news from overseas.
I saw that Kim Jong-un
just reappeared in public
for the first time in 36 days.
Tough news for North Korea --
when Kim Jong-un emerged,
he saw his shadow, which means
six more weeks of dictatorship.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Yep, Kim Jong-un hadn't attended
any social functions
in over a month.
So either something is wrong or
he was just doing Dry January.
Switching gears, Tom Brady
announced that, next year,
he will start his broadcasting
career at Fox Sports.
But the statement from
Fox Sports seemed a bit off.
Here, check this out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I didn't think
they'd release that.
-Huh?
-I didn't think
they'd release that.
You'd think they'd go,
"Oh, we made a mistake.
We'll keep it back."
You know what I mean?
But they let it out there.
That's great.
-I think they just went with,
like, a live commercial
and they just didn't
have the time.
You know, sometimes, you just
got to put that out there.
-Keep on going, yeah.
-Breaking news.
-Yeah, exactly.
Live commercials.
Everybody loves them.
-Yeah, so fun.
Well, people are
talking about this.
Apparently, the "Yellowstone"
series starring Kevin Costner
is set to end.
[ Audience groans ]
And a spin-off starring
Matthew McConaughey
could be in the works.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah, they already have
a title for it.
It's going to be called
"Yellowstoned."
Genius.
That's a good idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd watch that.
Did you guys hear about
a Kia recall?
It's not great.
Take a look at this.
-A recall alert if you drive
a Kia S.U.V.
The company is recalling
the Telluride three-row S.U.V.
over faulty second-row
side airbags.
-Aw, man!
I just bought a Kia S.U.V.
-Oh, Geez. I'm sorry, Tariq.
-It's all good.
I mean, at least I still have
my trusty Honda.
It's an older vehicle,
but that's okay.
-Oh.
-"Oh" what?
-Roll the clip.
-A recall alert
for you this morning.
Honda is urging owners of around
8,000 older vehicles
to not drive them.
The airbag inflaters
have a high possibility of
exploding and
hurling shrapnel in a crash.
-What?! How am I supposed to
get to my friend's
Super Bowl party this weekend?
-I'm not sure.
I'm sorry about that, Tariq.
-I had it all planned out.
I was going to bring
my charcuterie board.
I bought
six different packages --
excuse me, eight packages.
Eight different packages of
ready-to-eat meats.
-A recall alert for you,
and it deals with
your charcuterie board.
Six different packages -- excuse
me, eight different packages
of ready-to-eat meat could be
contaminated with listeria.
-Come on!
-It's a tough break.
Is there anything else
that you can bring to the party?
-Well, thankfully,
I'm always prepared.
In my kitchen right now,
I've got like
2.5 million pounds
of canned meat.
-There you go. That's perfect.
What time is the party?
-Well, kickoff is at 6:30,
but I'll get there a little bit
early, around six-twenty-fooa --
six-twenty-four.
-Time right now,
it is six-twenty-fooa --
six-twenty-four.
A recall alert
for something that may be
in your kitchen right now.
Conagra is recalling more than
2.5 million pounds
of canned meat.
-Are you kidding me?!
-Do you have anything else?
-I'd have to check my pantries.
Maybe my Rao's.
I have some 16-ounce jars of
made-for-home
slow-simmered soup.
They're labeled
chicken and...gnocchi?
-We have a recall alert
new at 5:30.
Check your pantries.
Rao's is recalling
some 16-ounce jars
of made-for-home
slow-simmered soup.
The affected jars are labeled
chicken and...gnocchi?
-Man, I give up!
-Why don't you come to my
Super Bowl party.
-Sure. What do you have planned?
-Well, you know
I live above Two Rivers Coffee,
so we're going to do
a hot-cocoa party,
because they have these cool
peanut-butter hot-chocolate pods
including Brooklyn
Peanut Butter Cup Hot Cocoa,
Pingo...Peanut...Butter...
Cookie...Hot...Chocolate,
and Cold Stone
Peanut Butter Cup Perfection.
-Oh.
-"Oh" what?
-Roll the clip.
-Two Rivers Coffee
is recalling its
peanut-butter
hot-chocolate pods,
including Brooklyn Bean
Peanut Butter Cup Hot Cocoa,
Pingo...Peanut...Butter...
Cookie...Hot...Chocolate,
and Cold Stone
Peanut Butter Cup Perfection.
-You know what? Forget it.
Just come over,
and we'll rewatch the Grammys.
Tariq Trotter, everybody.
-Jimmy Fallon.
-That is Tariq Trotter,
the one and only.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Wow.
Difficult to make plans.
Finally, experts in California
discovered a pretty crazy
issue at one house.
Check this out.
-A pest-control company
encountered a home
that had been experiencing
damage from a woodpecker.
And look at this.
The bird had been storing acorns
in the home's walls.
700 pounds of acorns.
-Oof!
The woodpecker was like, "Well,
there goes my Super Bowl party.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen!
-Let's go.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
We goin' all
the way up with this one.
"21 Pounds."
Ha!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much, everyone.
Welcome.
Before we start the show,
I just want to mention
UNICEF is on the ground
right now
supporting our friends in
Syria and Turkey.
They're providing access to
clean water, food,
and much more.
So if you're able to give,
please visit
unicefusa.org/tonightshow.
Every little bit counts.
We appreciate that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.